[Musik]
sagt das war's das jetzt nicht
das ist soll jetzt mal was geht und was
geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ja ich hoffe natürlich geht
es gut ich freue mich unglaublich das
ich jetzt sitzen kann und endlich dieses
video drehen kann ich wollte eigentlich
schon längst gemacht haben wir hatten
ein problem den gegenstand denn wir
hierfür brauchen
der war restlos ausverkauft ich habe
dann irgendwo herbekommen ich hab sogar
auf ins programm um hilfe gebeten ob
mich irgendwann bock hatte er in köln
wohnt und welche hat mir die kunst
auszuleihen
da wurde ich mal wieder von 212 jährigen
verarscht presse seit ist duo alex hat
die kann die ausleihen treibe ich cool
wo wir uns nicht abholen und ihr danach
wieder zurück bringen und dann sag ich
mal so kann's mir kurz ein bild davon
schicken weil ich halt weiß dass viel
einmischen und dann können wir also
zwölfjährige ich finde ich dann witzig
die machen dann so ein bild das man
halte also die hand würde und mir direkt
blockieren spaß doch so entschuldigung
auf jeden fall hier ich weiß gestern
morgen im apple store und habe die
airports privaten verfügung
doch die von action die hat nämlich
jetzt auch ich bin der mensch bilden
meist im alter zu diesen action kommt
auf dem nächsten video
aber heute geht es erstmal um diese hier
und das sind die airports wofür ich habe
den richtigen stoff macht er ja die sind
so günstig in der hand 280 euro kostet
das ist echt so eine menge geld für
kopfhörer
wenn die nichts können oder wenn ihr
mich nicht überzeugen bringe ich die
wieder zeugt ist ja ganz klar weil hier
auch schon direkt als die bei insider
gepostet habe kam zu antworten bin haben
als wenn ich die verloren obwohl ich
weiß nicht solche verlosen am ende das
sagen
ich könnte aber eigentlich immer kurz
die erste generation die ich habe dazu
also die airports die man halt so kennt
so wir haben wir die jedermann kennt
habe ich auch schon sich videos gezeigt
und jetzt ich mache es einfach mal auf
oder also verpackungen ist wirklich
schon entlastet mal sehen
280 euro jetzt kann man das hier einfach
so abziehen
[Applaus]
heute machen was man wirklich so dass
wir von oben nach unten auspacken
die riechen so neu designed by apple in
california und hergestellt
ja ich habe mal der beschreibung fan von
betreibern bin ich natürlich eher
weniger gut wie das funktioniert das
weiß ich schon das legen wir mal zur
seite
auch mal nicht und hier haben wir auch
schon die airports er trägt immer
eigentlich kann man sogar sagen also die
form von case ist wenn man sie so hält
ähnlich nur dass die halter eigentlich
dann so gehören naja gut und habe hier
noch nie in den laden kam aber kein
wunder dass us pc in leipzig dass das
ist ja bei den neuen macbooks auch so
die haben ja alle solche anschlüsse
beste seite ist das ja ich finde es auch
nicht schon als und hier haben wir noch
immer das sind dann wahrscheinlich diese
stöpsel die kommen dann da drauf weil
ich habe gehört also im ernst wenn auch
zum ersten mal ich wusste gar nicht dass
es diese technologie schon gibt dass die
praktischen noise cancelling haben das
heißt wenn die jetzt in der bahn sitzt
und ein kleines kind schreibt dass das
so ausgefüllt hat wird oder irgendwas
umfeld keine ahnung dass mal gar nichts
mehr von der auswahl wird bekommt und ob
das wirklich so gut funktioniert das
weiß ich noch nicht aber es ist ja
natürlich auch fragte ich hier mal meine
280 euro dinge aus kannst du mal sowieso
eine engelsstimme machen im hintergrund
nochmals der stadt durch den kopf okay
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt schon gesagt wenn ich so
meine oma jetzt diese dinger zeigen
würden unsere fragen was das kostet
würde ich sagen wo zwölf mag also ich
bin schon man merkt auf jeden fall dass
da wirklich also das ist nicht billig ne
was man mir nach antrag sich immer
irgendwie ein bisschen verkoppelt aus
oder guckt mal
naja jetzt hole ich mir erstmal hier die
airports der ersten generation raus und
da erkennt man natürlich einen leichten
unterschied hier fake original na ja
also das ist was ganz anderes
der verkäufer meinte auch zu mir
vielleicht gefällt dir das hier nicht
mit dem kopf da drin weil die steckt man
ja so richtig tief ins ohr rein da haben
soll mehrere kunden schon ein problem
mit gab
mal schauen ich habe jetzt heute gedacht
ich du erstmal noch mal einer normalen
er post oder meine alten airports jetzt
ja ins ohr und höher
kurz rein damit ich einmal so dieses
sounderlebnis hat und dann gleich
schauen kann auf das sounderlebnis
hiervon krasser ist und wir schauen uns
auch mal so ein paar funktionen hiervon
an
wie gesagt noise cancelling etc etc
komm mit mir okay das reicht mir auch
schon ich bin wirklich alles von den
dingern falsch bis heute ist er gut ich
habe mir auch damals überlegt soll ich
mir jetzt eben wie um im zug oder
sonstwo wenn ich unterwegs bin zur
arbeit und des herz- oder meinte juli
nehmen die airports und das habe ich bis
heute bereue also juli keine airports
hast du keine r
und jetzt connect das richtige erzähler
eltern was sagst du zum neuen case für
nicht gut ich würde sogar fast sagen das
gefällt mir mehr als das alte oder warst
du schon eisbär ports pro das sieht doch
nein zu hassen
sonst kann ja auch einfach meine alten
airports umgenäht post zum flexen sind
schon connected dann würde ich sagen
reden wir auch gar nicht lange im heißen
warum und machen direktion check oder
bereich hatte die noch gar nicht im ohr
somit richtig sagt boah was das jetzt
nicht gedacht dass es so heftig jetzt
was geht ab hörst du mich ganz ganz
leise alter es hört man echt mal richtig
leid jetzt ist ja so und wahrscheinlich
auch noch richtig geklotzt
da wird mir jetzt ein bisschen
schwindelig schon bei ist das so richtig
dunkel das so richtig dampf ruhig
überwand das ist halt alle alten selbst
david krasner ich würde sagen ihr wollt
mich gut ich war nix mehr und ich mach
mal kurz den song an
jetzt bin ich gespannt
normalerweise hört man ja seine eigene
stimme wenn man bz trotzdem wenn die
musik lauter ist technisch also ist klar
bei dir was genau ich habe gar nichts
redner bisschen lauter alexander bekommt
bei diabetes überhaupt nicht ganz bis
das war schon laut also musik ist echt
die also das musikerlebnis ist richtig
gut ich weiß jetzt nicht auch nicht wenn
es vielleicht im raum ist würde ich gar
nicht mal sagen das ist bei denen
geschlechter ist aber diese noise
cancelling funktionen hohe haftung
ich weiß nicht ob das an meinem handy
league ich habe ja mittlerweile das sehr
veraltete iphone 7 + wenn ich jetzt hier
auf die lautstärke drücke kommt halt
hier geräusch kontrolle focus es kann
nicht ein und ausmachen sagte mal so es
ist aussagen was genau jetzt möchte ich
halt wieder richtig laut also das ist
wohl diese neue scans link funktion
ich habe allerdings dass er auch schon
bei leuten gesehen die in iphone 11 oder
ein iphone apps haben da gibt's hier
viel mehr funktionen reicht rocken kann
ich auch nicht das neueste update aber
auch nicht deswegen geht es nicht so wie
ich es mir vorgestellt hatte
lass mal kurz das update machen oder
melden wir uns wieder komme also ich hab
das update jetzt gemacht haben schon ein
bisschen später hat echt lang gedauert
hier werden wir jetzt gerade so ein paar
sachen angezeigt na gut ist jedoch schon
anders aus dummer jetzt kann man hier
verschiedene modi wechseln jetzt sind
wir dabei geräuschunterdrückung das
heißt ich überhaupt gar nichts das kann
man auch ausstellen und transparenz bin
ich was ist das hallo hallo hallo hallo
jetzt möchte ich aber ganz komisch
richtig wir können noch kurz zum
mikrofon test machen obwohl das
mikrophon bombastisch ist was ja
mindestens genauso gut wie bei der
zweiten generation und da war es schon
gut und was man auch noch aufgefallen
wir müssen den knopf sein
ich weiß auch nicht wie es kein nachteil
die ganzen kombis muss ich mir da noch
aussuchen muss ich jetzt nicht darüber
reden ich bin ja kein technik kanal ich
wollte nur einfach mal testen und es ist
schon was was du hier auf jeden fall
fürs leben jetzt ein bisschen weiter
gebracht hat das ist sowas schon gibt
höchst interessant das war ganz kurz das
mikrofon testen dann war es eigentlich
auch schon an idee ist auch meine
meinung wissen wollen ob die sich lohnen
oder ob das preis-leistungs-verhältnis
stimmt also die dinger sind wirklich
krass vor allem das feature mit dem
neues cancelling ich wusste nicht dass
es sowas schon gibt also das hat mich
echt fasziniert trotzdem muss ich sagen
für 280 euro
ich finde das ist zu viel geld dafür ich
habe mal geguckt in amerika kosten die
249 dollar
also noch mal ein kleines stückchen
weniger als dann hier umgerechnet in
euro aber ist trotzdem so viel geld also
ich glaube auch dass ich bei meinem
alten bäume
die frage ist jetzt was macht dann
bringe ich die wieder zurück verlor sich
die wir machen jetzt vom mikrofon und
ich bin ihm einen neuen boss orange
leisten
er hat sich nur das mikrofon an preis
aber total brutal gut warnwesten also
noch sagen dass es bei der wir können
wieso kommt nach 20 stunden hat meine
stimme aus dem handy sei jetzt kommt
deine jetzt von jeweils gut aber ich bin
jetzt ein bisschen verwirrt hier warum
bereiten meine stimme aus deinem handy
kam
komisch aber das funktioniert
alles wäre ich irgendwie als wenn ihr
noch an mir dran gewesen okay doch ich
habe jetzt folgendes gedacht wenn dieses
video 10.000 likes bekommt ich behalte
bis morgen also bis morgen um diese
uhrzeit und nehmens montag sagen bis
montag dann stelle ich die buy ins
allgemeine sorry ins album alex wie
könnte abchecken und dann schreibe ich
irgendwann an die bekommt gerne danach
mit beweisfoto dass ich das machen ja
sonst eher selten aber gut es ist auch
nicht so teuer gut dass alte leute das
war's mit dem video nach oben kann
abonnieren glock aktivieren wir sehen
uns morgen um 20 uhr wiederholt rein